هكذا قالها الرئيس الأوكراني زيلينسكي
(تعال واجلس معي! ماذا بك؟
تعال ولا تخف! اجلس معي
فأنا لست كلبا لأعضك).
قصف وحريق في محطة أكبر مفاعل نووي
في أوروبا،
هل تتعمد موسكو تفجير المفاعل؟
أم أنها مجرد تهديدات لبث الرعب
في الغرب وأوروبا؟ ....
موسكو تؤكد نجاح مخططاتها في كييف...
أمن أوروبا في خطر فما الحل الآن
بالنسبة لهم؟
رئيس أوكرانيا يطلب الجلوس على طاولة
المفاوضات وبوتين يهدد الغرب وأوروبا
مرة أخرى،
واتهامات بين الجانبين بخسائر
تقدر بعشرات الآلاف من القتلى في قواتهم،
وسط تعاقد مع عشرات الآلاف من المرتزقة الجدد....
(كارثة متوقعة)
استهداف مفاعل زابوريجيا النووي
بقصف روسي..
وهذه صور تظهر استهداف
القذائف لمحطة زابوريجيا بالقرب من
المفاعل واندلاع حريق فيها...
ليخرج رئيس وزراء بريطانيا بوريس جونسن،
ويطالب روسيا بوقف هجومها على محطة
زابوريجيا النووية فورا...
ويضيف جونسن: إن إجراءات بوتين
"المتهورة" تعرض أمن كل أوروبا للخطر،،
بينما طالب الرئيس الأوكراني
بفرض عقوبات "أقوى" على موسكو
بعد قصف المنشأة النووية الأوكرانية.
واتهم زيلنسكي موسكو باللجوء إلى ما وصفه
بـ "الإرهاب النووي" والرغبة في "تكرار"
كارثة تشيرنوبيل.
وقال زيلينسكي في رسالة بالفيديو
"ما من دولة غير روسيا أطلقت النار
على وحدات للطاقة النووية.
هذه هي المرة الأولى في تاريخنا،
في تاريخ البشرية، الدولة الإرهابية لجأت الآن
إلى الإرهاب النووي".
أما الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
فيؤكد سير العمليات العسكرية في أوكرانيا
بنجاح وكما هو مخطط لها..
..
وهنا الرئيس الأوكراني زيلينسكي يوجه
رسالة لبوتين:
أجلس معي لنتحدث فأنا لا أعض...
وما الذي تريده من أرضنا؟ اذهب بعيدا عنا!!!....
بينما تستمر المعارك في العديد من الجبهات
على الأراضي الأوكرانية،
في هجوم روسي متواصل واستماتة
في التصدي من جانب قوات أوكرانيا،
(التطورات والأحداث)
المتمردون المدعومون من روسيا يحاولون التقدم
أكثر في دونباس، في حين يتحدثون عن سيطرتهم
على مزيد من المدن
كما تم سماع صفارات الإنذار في دونيبرو شرقا
والفيف غربا.. والعاصمة كييف تشهد
انفجارات متتالية.
..
أعلنت المحكمة الجنائية الدولية
بدء التحقيق بشأن ارتكاب جرائم حرب
محتملة في أوكرانيا
قطر تعرب عن قلقها بشأن التصعيد العسكري
وتداعياته في أوكرانيا، وتحاول بذل جهودها
الديبلوماسية لإيجاد حلول للأزمة
هبوط قياسي في العملة الروسية الروبل،
بسبب العقوبات الاقتصادية المفروضة على موسكو،
والأضرار لا تقتصر على روسيا فقط
بل حتى الدول التي فرضت العقوبات
تتكبد خسائر كبيرة أيضا..
الناتو يتوعد روسيا بدفع ثمن حربها،
مطالبا بوتين بوقف الحرب على الفور.
وسط منع لتحليق طائرات الناتو
في الأجواء الأوكرانية
..
بينما أعلنت وكالة تفتيش المواقع النووية
الأوكرانية  أنها لم ترصد أي تسرب إشعاعي
من منشأة زابوريجيا النووية في جنوب البلاد
والتي تعرضت لضربات روسية.
..
موسكو تهدد أن أي اختراق لقمر صناعي روسي
سيكون ردنا هو الحرب،،
وبذلك تتجنب روسيا أي هجوم سيبرأني
على فضائها الصناعي...
وزير خارجية روسيا سيرجي لافروف
: أوكرانيا لديها الإمكانات والتكنولوجيا
لتصنيع سلاح نووي،،
ولن نسمح بسلاح عسكري على حدودنا،،
والغرب سيخسر الكثير بتسليحه لكييف...
نحن قادرون على مواجهة كل أشكال الضغط
ومن يشكك في ذلك أنصحه أن يتعرف أكثر
على التاريخ الروسي...
على صعيد آخر، أعلن المفاوضون الروس والأوكرانيون
إحراز تقدم محدود في محادثات وقف إطلاق النار،
واتفق الجانبان على ضرورة وجود ممرات
إنسانية للمدنيين.
بينما قال مسؤول أوكراني بارز إنه على الرغم
من هذه النتيجة، فإن المحادثات لم تفضِ إلى النتائج
التي كانت تأمل فيها كييف.
...
زيلينسكي يقول:
تقريبا هناك ٩٢٠٠ قتيل من الجنود الروس ..
وهناك محاولة من موسكو لدخول كييف
ولكن عاصمتنا عصية عليهم
...
تقارير روسية:
تجنيد لمتعاقدين من شركات أمريكية
بهدف تعويض الخسائر الأوكرانية..
مع توقع  لوصول نحو١٦ألف من الجنود المرتزقة
الأجانب لينضموا لقوات كييف الموجودة
على الأرض ولتعويض الخسائر الفادحة في قواتهم..
بحسب التقارير..
مشاهد لتدمير موقع قيادة عسكرية في دونيتسك
بواسطة مسيرة روسية.
إسرائيل تُأمِن طيرانها إلى روسيا بهدف استمرار رحلاتها،،
وتقول حكومة تل أبيب
إن تسيير رحلاتها نحو روسيا لإبقاء الاتصال
مع رعايها هناك ومساعدتهم في العودة إلى البلاد..
رحلتا طيران تسيران يوميا بين تل أبيب وموسكو
لشركتي إيرفلوت الروسية  وإل عال الإسرائيلية،،
وقد تعهدت إسرائيل بتعويض أي خسائر
قد تنجم عن هذه الرحلات لشركة إل عال..
تستمر الأخبار من هنا وهناك بين أخبار صادقة
وإشاعات مغرضة، فالمنتصر قد يزيف انتصاراته
والخاسر قد يحور خساراته،
كما هي عادات الحروب وبين هذا وذاك
لا بد من ضحايا للحروب ومعظمهم من الأبرياء
خصوصا الأطفال والنساء والشيوخ،
وهذه هي لعنة الحروب التي يتحدثون عنها،
لكن قد لا يتوقف الأمر على الدول المتحاربة
هذه المرة، ولا حتى على الدول المجاورة لها
بل قد يصل طرف الأمر إلى كل دولة موجودة
على الكرة الأرضية،
فهل تستمر الحرب هكذا باتجاه المجهول؟..